>>> THIS MORNING THE SEVEN
AMERICANS WHO WERE WRONGFULLY
DETAINED IN VENEZUELA ARE BACK
IN THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCING
SATURDAY THE RETURN OF THE
HOSTAGES FIVE WERE PART OF THE
S
CITGO SIX.
THEY WERE FREED IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE RELEASE OF TWO NEPHEWS OF
VENEZUELA'S FIRST LADY.
THEY WERE CONVICTED ON DRUG
CHARGES.
THESE RELEASES ADD TO THE
GROWING LIST OF AMERICAN
HOSTAGES FREED UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JOINING ME IS THE
RELATIVE OF TWO OF THE SEVEN
RELEASED.
WE'RE THRILLED YOU'RE GETTING
YOUR FATHER AND UNCLE HOME.
TELL US ABOUT THAT MOMENT THAT
YOU LEARNED THAT THEY WERE BEING
RELEASED.
>> IT WAS LIKE THE BIGGEST
RELIEF AND FEELING OF EUPHORIA I
COULD EVER DESCRIBE.
I HAD, IRONICALLY TURNED MY
PHONE OFF FOR 30 MINUTES TO DO
SOME EXERCISE AND GET MY MIND
OFF OF THINGS AND IN THAT 30
MINUTES WE WERE FINDING OUT
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
ONCE I TURNED MY PHONE BACK ON
AND GOT BACK TO IT, MY
BROTHER-IN-LAW CALLED ME AND I
WAS ACTUALLY JUST ON A SIDEWALK
AND I LIKE FELL OVER JUST CRYING
AND -- TEARS OF HAPPINESS.
SO IT WAS, YOU KNOW, MAYBE NOT
WHERE I WANTED TO FIND OUT, BUT
I WAS SO THANKFUL AND I'VE JUST
BEEN THANKFUL EVER SINCE.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> DID YOU KNOW THIS WAS IN THE
WORKS?
DID YOU KNOW THIS NEWS WAS GOING
TO BE COMING?
>> WE HAD SOME SENSE AMONG THE
FAMILIES IN THE MORNING THAT
SOMETHING WAS OFF.
SOME COMMUNICATIONS MAYBE THAT
WE REGULARLY GET FROM OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS, ET CETERA, SOME THINGS
Z
SEEMED A LITTLE OFF.
SOME FOOD DELIVERIES, WHERE THE
GUARDS WERE SAYING THEY WERE NO
LONGER THERE.
IT WAS SEVERAL HOURS OF A LOT OF
CONFUSION AND CONCERN AND HOPE.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE WERE SO
RELIEVED TO FIND OUT THAT THIS
TIME THEY WERE REALLY COMING
HOME.
>> WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE FOR
YOUR FAMILY TO HAVE YOUR FATHER
AND YOUR UNCLE NOT JUST AWAY BUT
IN CAPTIVITY FOR ALL THIS TIME?
>> OH, GOD.
IT'S JUST BEEN LIKE ONE OF THE
MOST TRAUMATIC THINGS YOU COULD
IMAGINE.
NOT ONLY ARE YOU JUST WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
EVERY SINGLE DAY, THEIR LITERAL
LIFE.
BUT THEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACTUALLY GET THEM OUT OF THERE
AND BECOME AN ACTIVIST AND A
MEDIA PERSON.
SO IT'S BEEN QUITE A TRIAL AND
TRIBULATION.
BUT I'M SO THANKFUL THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THEM HOME FINALLY.
YOU KNOW, WITH THE HELP OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND AMBASSADOR
CARSON.
I'M JUST BEYOND THANKFUL FOR
THAT.
>> AMBASSADOR CARSON IS IN
CHARGE OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WHO NEGOTIATES THESE RELEASE.
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SEE YOUR
FATHER, HE'S AT A HOSPITAL RIGHT
NOW.
BUT HAS HE DISCUSSED WITH YOU,
IN THAT LIMITED TIME THAT YOU'VE
SEEN HIM, HOW HE WAS TREATED AND
WHAT THE CONDITIONS WERE IN
CAPTIVITY?
>> YOU KNOW, WE DID GET TO SEE
HIM FOR ABOUT AN HOUR YESTERDAY,
WHICH WAS EXTREMELY AMAZING.
AND IT WAS LONGER THAN I THOUGHT
I'D GET BECAUSE OF THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT AND PROGRAM THAT
THEY'RE A PART OF RIGHT NOW TO
HELP, YOU KNOW, GET THEM BACK
INTO NORMAL LIFE HERE.
SO WE WANTED TO BE MINDFUL OF
THAT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I THINK THE PAST 24 TO 48
HOURS HAVE BEEN AS CRAZY FOR HIM
AS IT HAS BEEN FOR US.
I THINK HE'S A MAN OF FAITH AND
I THINK HE HAS A LOT OF TROUBLE
CONDEMNING OTHERS FOR WHAT HE'S
GONE THROUGH AND HE'S TRYING TO
F
FOCUS ON THE GRATITUDE OF BEING
HOME.
BUT I COULD SEE SOME PAIN IN HIS
EYES AS HE, YOU KNOW, DISCUSSED
EVEN THE FINAL MOMENTS OF TRYING
TO GET ON THE PLANE TO COME
HERE.
HE WAS IN SHACKLES.
HE WAS BOUND.
THEY, YOU KNOW, TREATED HIM LIKE
A PRISONER UNTIL THE VERY LAST
MOMENT.
SO YOU KNOW, I THINK HE'S VERY
HAPPY TO BE HOME AND HERE WITH
US.
>> AS WE NOTED, THESE MEN, THESE
AMERICANS, HELD HOSTAGE, WERE
RELEASED AS PART OF A SWAP.
TWO OF THE NEPHEWS OF THE FIRST
LADY OF VENEZUELA WERE HANDED
BACK IN EXCHANGE.
THIS IS WHAT FLORIDA SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THIS EXCHANGE.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> EVERY TIME YOU DO ONE OF
THESE DEALS, I WANTED THOSE
PEOPLE RELEASED AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY BUT EVERY TIME YOU DO
THIS, NOW OTHERS KNOW I CAN TAKE
AMERICANS, HOLD THEM, UNTIL I
NEED SOMETHING AS A BARGAINING
CHIP.
WHAT THAT HAS DONE IS SENT A
MESSAGE TO TYRANTS AND DICTATORS
AROUND THE WORLD TO TRUMP UP
CHARGES BECAUSE WHEN THE TIME
COMES WE'LL BE ABLE TO EXCHANGE
THEM.
SO SEVEN AMERICANS FOR TWO
NEPHEWS OF MA DORO IS A WIN FOR
MA DORO AND PUTS AMERICANS IN
DANGER ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT?
>> I FIND THOSE COMMENTS ARE
UNHELPFUL AND MISINFORMED.
A LEADER IN THIS COUNTRY IS
PERPETUATING A MYTH THAT GETTING
OUR PEOPLE HOME PUTS PEOPLE AT
RISK.
I WOULD ASK SENATOR RUBIO, YOU
SUPPORTED GETTING THEM HOME?
YOU HAVE DONE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
FOR ME OR MY FAMILY OR MOST OF
THESE MEN AND ANY OF THE
FAMILIES CAN TELL YOU THAT.
HE HAD A CONSISTENT FROM HIS
STATE THAT WAS RELEASED AND I
WOULD ASK, WHAT DID YOU DO FOR
HIM FAMILY AND HOW HAVE YOU BEEN
SUPPORTING THEM?
HAVE YOU CHECKED IN ON THEM
INSTEAD OF PANDERING TO YOUR
CONSISTENCY?
I FIND HIS COMMENTS UNPATRIOTIC
AND UNHELPFUL.
>> WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE BUT
WE ARE SO HAPPY FOR YOU, YOUR
FAMILY, WISHING ALL OF YOU THE
VERY BEST AS YOUR FATHER AND
YOUR UNCLE AND THE OTHERS SETTLE
BACK INTO NORMAL LIFE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WISHING YOU ALL THE VERY BEST.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR